It's virtually guaranteed that if you're a
superhero in the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
your family is full of tragedy. Even with the
stiff competition from folks like Thor and Peter
Parker, it's hard to point out a super-family
with more ongoing drama than the Wakandan royalty.
In "Captain America: Civil
War," King T'Chaka dies,
leaving his distraught son T'Challa seeking
vengeance. In "Black Panther," we find out
that young T'Chaka killed his exiled criminal
brother N'Jobu, which sends the latter's son
N'Jadaka on a path that turns him into
Killmonger, the movie's main antagonist.
“I found my daddy with panther claws in
his chest. You ain't the son of a king,
you the son of a murderer.”
Warning: We're about to get into major spoilers.
“Tell me the spoilers,
child…and embrace your destiny!”
"Black Panther: Wakanda Forever" doubles down
on the tragedy trend. In addition to depicting
T'Challa's death, a necessary plot point to
reflect the real-world death of star Chadwick
Boseman, Queen Ramonda also dies during the
events of the movie. After Queen Ramonda's death,
it seems that T'Challa's younger sister Shuri
is the only remaining member of her family,
leading her down a path of violent revenge…from
which she veers away at the last minute.
However, the movie's mid-credits scene actually
reveals a new member of the Wakandan royal family:
We discover that T'Challa actually fathered
a son with Nakia. As the latter introduces
Shuri to young Toussaint, he reveals that
his Wakandan name is, in fact T'Challa.
With a name like that, it seems like Marvel
Studios is setting the child up to become a huge
part of the MCU many years down the line. Still,
major Marvel fans might already have noticed that
the MCU origin of the character is quite different
from T'Challa's son in the pages of Marvel Comics.
There, his full name is Azari T'Challa —
and he's the son of T'Challa and Storm,
a longtime member of the X-Men. This version of
the character is actually from an alternate future
timeline from the mainline Marvel Comics
timeline, and he's a teenage mutant who's
inherited both his father's Black Panther powers
and his mother's power to control lightning.
This, of course, is a significantly
different origin story from the one
"Wakanda Forever's" T'Challa Jr. gets.
For starters, he's still just a small
child when we meet him. And we have
no idea whether he's inherited any
of the powers that were granted to his
father by Wakanda's heart shaped herb.
Though messing with a characters' background in
live action adaptations might annoy some fans,
it's understandable that the MCU plays fast and
loose with T'Challa's family tree. Since Storm
hasn't been officially introduced in the MCU, and
"Black Panther" star Chadwick Boseman's death in
2020 ended King T'Challa's story, there's no way
for the two to meet — let alone start a family.
Meanwhile, Nakia is T'Challa's former
lover and obviously ongoing romantic
interest in "Black Panther," and
her lengthy absence from the MCU
after the first "Black Panther" movie
is easily explained by the fact that
she's been in Haiti, keeping the heir
to Wakanda's throne safe and hidden.
It's an interesting move to introduce T'Challa's
son at this exact point in the MCU timeline.
Not only does his existence strongly hint
that the Black Panther's legacy will
continue even after Shuri — but it also works
wonders for her, the current Black Panther.
After all, Shuri's lost all the family members
that she knew of in relatively rapid succession,
and is finally starting to resolve her grief
and trauma by the time "Wakanda Forever" ends.
The mid-credit scene's revelation that she's not
the last living member of her family dovetails
perfectly with her character arc of accepting
her losses, and honoring her family's legacy.
"Black Panther: Wakanda
Forever" is now in theaters.